maybe all the Italian companies can sew
a patch on his back for sponsorship and
he has to walk around shirtless like a
NASCAR yeah Yeah so basically it would
be Ferrari
Ferragamo
Versace I think it's fair for everyone
[Music]
anybody see that clip of a tourist who
was carving his and his girl's initials
into the Coliseum into the Coliseum
that's not allowed you can't do that
let me Google can you check please yeah
are you sure that's illegal I didn't
know they weren't Gladiators huh
are they are they Europeans pay their
respects were they like I remember the
Canadians Canadians that is very
surprising that's very American Behavior
it was a British tourist okay okay it
sounds British sounds British
Canadian guys with doing similar stuff
in Japan I remember oh really death
penalty man I'm kind of for it a little
bit I do believe in the concept of When
in Rome and they're literally in Rome
yeah yeah but the Romans don't even do
that that's not the do is the Romans
they don't do petrol glyphs
I don't think they vandalize their own
historical sites what if he was inspired
by the artworks of Michelangelo and he
wanted to start carving himself he wrote
Ivan plus Haley 23.
I hope they break up can't help him
there
that is so whack dude you know I didn't
know this but uh the UK is a poorer
America did you guys know that and what
do you mean what do you mean by that I I
was shocked I thought that the UK
because of Harry Potter and British
people I thought they were like classy
or sophisticated sophisticated bro
that's just London outside man that
they're like ours
hardcore or that's more Oxford but yeah
that's like Hawks area yeah nah dude
that there are dude yeah Deliverance
just everywhere else
they're drunk fighting ass happy ass
dude yeah they're like man I was like I
like you guys I thought you were [__]
plug up the butt oh dear [__]
yeah they're actually more relatable
than you think huh yeah dude they're
good I like that there are forefathers
I see where you know West Virginia came
from now yeah they're like the two
fathers yeah
all right here's the clip they're broke
as [__] still just like a bunch of broke
boys oh man
oh good there's evidence
why would you do that man
so the guy filmed me goes are you
serious man oh he's filming him and this
guy cusses at him
[Music]
is this girl next room like you're so
romantic and net in it
so romantic and that let me guess
are you thirsty I'll get you
did they say that does it say they said
that yeah can you check yeah it says
so this British tourist though
um he uh ignorantly claims that he
didn't realize how old it was he didn't
realize oh why is he even there
that's not bad you're telling me he
coincidentally ended up next to the
Coliseum and just thought it was a race
he should have just confessed his love
for his his lady he's like I just love
my lady so much we had to carve our
initials in the wall that would have
been better than [__] I didn't know
it was that old that's not bad that's a
terrible [__] excuse why is she
putting something so all right here
should be in the museum I like that age
determines whether or not to vandalize
something yeah dude's like like that
matters I have those uh oh like hey this
just got built why aren't you carving
that how new is this when you go to
Europe though there's so much old [__]
that it just feels like I can carve my
there's um there's another there's just
everywhere but the best part is you
don't realize it yeah yeah that's true
some of these buildings be like
thousands of years old and [__] yeah and
the specific notoriety of the Roman
Coliseum is is a protected UNESCO world
heritage site like it's who the [__]
doesn't know the Colosseum so is he
gonna get in trouble what kind of
troubles are you getting can they send
him to Bangkok or they whoop his ass or
something yeah yeah Singapore see they
act like he did that in Singapore
to the Mandalay can they export the
punishment I want to go to the Coliseum
they that was the original UFC it's
pretty cool because he was tight costume
is badass uh the man was later
identified as British man Ivan dimitrov
a 27 year old fitness instructor living
in Bristol who now faces a fine and even
potential prison term yes that's sad
teach Fitness in jail
[Laughter]
he has since written a letter of apology
to uh the mayor of Rome saying that only
now does he realize the seriousness of
the deed committed [__] he just
sorry he got caught he's trying to go to
jail right in the letter he wrote quote
through these lines I would like to
address my heartfelt and honest
apologies to the Italians and to the
whole world for the damage caused to an
asset which in fact is the heritage of
all Humanity that's a chat gbt apology
for sure and then he wants to carve his
apologies on the walls I'm so sorry
a regular Martin Luther
he praised those who will guard the
inestimable uh historical and artistic
value of the Coliseum with dedication
care and sacrifice it is with deep
embarrassment that only after what
regrettably happened did I learn of the
Antiquity of the monument oh my God they
should just like be allowed to carve on
his back yeah Adidas Italia
it's pretty good I think I think I think
it's fair to get flogged for something
like this Vlog but Vlog just temporary
right carving on his back is forever
just like on the brick what if what if
he gets hit with like
a Fiat or something yeah it's too small
yeah it would do what the Romans do we
have to fly the Tiger
that's really they bring the Coliseum
back and he's the he's the beginning
show yeah oh I want to see the Coliseum
back in Action Lions versus criminal oh
yeah carving his back is probably the
best one but you're right yeah so he's
now under investigation for damaging a
cultural heritage and faces a fine of
between 2500 and 15 000 Euros as well as
a prison sentence of two to five years
dude they should carve sabaro on his
back
best pizza joint around maybe all the
Italian companies can sew a patch on his
back for sponsorship and he has to walk
around shirtless like a NASCAR yeah yeah
yeah so then they get free promotion
Yeah so basically it would be Ferrari
Ferragamo
Versace everybody wins everybody wins I
think it's fair for everyone
[Laughter]
all the Pasadena Italian restaurants
that's good man pardino Brothers yeah
and they just bid for how big they want
their Spaghetti Factory
um
have you guys been to an Old Spaghetti
Factory
I seen it I just never been I haven't
been to a spaghetti how many of you guys
been to Italy though
oh you so lucky me and Joe haven't gone
how's the taste of the food there the
best and you're amazing it is really
good yeah amazing it's very good I think
hands down best so they're like they
deserve their food snobbery unlike
France because France are they're really
snobby about food but they [__] suck
do you think their food is trash it's so
bad I went to two Michelin restaurants
there it was so bad what was bad about
the the Michelin star restaurants to me
yeah well it's your to me okay I feel
like when you grow up eating
um really buttery Rich things right you
build that palette for it so then the
older you get you want greasier crazy or
[__] and I feel like all they do is
drink espresso smoke cigarettes drink
wine and [__] eat a bagel and kill
their taste buds or pastry croissant
croissant or whatever right
and then they eat these like really high
fat weird things that to me I'm like
Mal's getting constipated for like so
many days my favorite food in France was
Italian food and Japanese food like even
at the fresh food is the opposite from
Mexican food basically
yeah it is the opposite it is Mexican
food is bomb
I don't know but I did not like french
food even at the Michelin star
restaurants yeah I'm like why are you
guys so snobby when this [__] is so bad
because of Ratatouille dude
but Italian food in France was so good I
was I went to a a pizza like specialty
joint in uh in Venice
and uh they have like their tomato
sauces there was like 13 different
tomato sauces that you could even choose
from so it's like you don't usually go
to a pizza place they have one standard
tomato sauce across all pizzas yeah 13
different ragus yeah different different
ragus species of tomatoes and so like
like the way that they can customize the
pizza is insane and then uh
it took two minutes to cook wow like
when I thought I ordered the pizza I
thought I was gonna be like okay like
we're gonna chill I'll use the restroom
and as soon as I got the rest how did
they cook it so fast well because they
have their own special like
um what is it called like Neapolitan
like style where it goes in at eight or
nine hundred degrees in like a special
like
so it's just it's like their microwave
no it's like a um it's like a brick oven
it's like a brick oven yeah high heat
they pull it in pull it out it comes out
the bottom is crispy right above it it's
like soft because it's thin and then the
tomato sauce is made right then and
there so it's not like they they season
the tomato sauce and then they sit they
let it sit there for a whole day it's
like you see like tomato chunks on it so
like whenever you order the tomatoes is
crushed right so it's like crazy fresh
like the flavors are bright as [__] so
when you bite into it you're like oh I
wish it was pepperoni on yeah well they
have pepperoni too but you're like God
damn this is CR it's like all the
flavors jump out at you it's insane hey
butt secret pizza at the cosmo in Las
Vegas it's really good what is it is it
like it's Italy is it different why is
it so good it's just [__] bomb what's
secret Pizza I need to go check it out
it's uh it's like a little restaurant
that has honestly just one of the
sickest pizzas period what is it it's
hella thick it's like a thick pie but I
don't just the way they make it yeah I
like the way you say thick Chicago type
of pizza I like those yeah it's kind of
deep dishes but like I don't think
Chicago when I eat it it's just it's
just good oh dude it makes me want pizza
now so when you guys were in Italy did
you eat every day like oh my God this is
so good honestly yeah yeah oh I'm going
to it and and like oh I want to go there
next and like um everywhere too so like
everywhere I go I like to get street
food and I like to get like a nice
restaurant even the street food like
like a tourist place outside of the
Coliseum where it's like a a
refrigerator and the the sandwich is
already pre-made and then when you pick
it they just heat it up for you even
something as simple as that was good and
then the lotto right after oh yeah
what's that gelato you get gelato do
they have mango
that's my favorite one oh really oh yeah
they got mango we got cantaloupe I don't
know about that one that's a little bit
more of a rarity
mango gelato is my favorite but they
probably have more Italian ones like
pistachio or something espresso they got
espresso yeah they got espresso they
have guava
oh have you tried uh licorice gelato no
no black licorice is it good oh you like
black licorice oh yeah yeah I mean I
can't I can't chew a licorice or
anything but the the ice cream is great
yeah gelato is really good Pasadena got
some nice gelato places oh yeah you
should take them I don't even know where
they are old town right yeah
[Music]